while big data brings us valuable
insights and opportunities
it also brings the responsibility to
ensure the data is secure
meaning that only the right data is
shared with the right people
in today's episode of bigquery spotlight
we're talking about how to use google
cloud's identity and access management
service to define which users can query
in your projects
and access your data sets
[Music]
bigquery is a fully managed service that
means it takes advantage of google's
infrastructure security
google secures its infrastructure end to
end from physical security of its
services
to stringent operational practices but
today's episode is about the role you
play in keeping your projects and data
secure
specifically how you share project and
data set access with different end users
and groups in your company
the key to managing access to your
projects and data is the identity and
access management service or iam
cloud iam allows you to manage access
control by defining three things
member role and policy meaning you
specify who
has what access to which resource let's
take a closer look at each of these
first the member or who has access you
can define a member
in several ways one way is to identify
end users by their email address if it's
associated with a google account
you can also set access for a group of
users by using a google group
g suite domain or cloud identity domain
as the member
sometimes it's not a person but an
application or service that needs access
to your bigquery data
in this case you can create a service
account which is a special type of
google account intended to represent a
non-human user
when you create a service account it is
assigned a special
address which can be used as the
member's identity when defining access
want to give a data set access to any
login user
there is a special identifier called all
authenticated users which you can use as
the member in this case
this is exactly how we make our bigquery
public data sets available to all
bigquery users
once you've defined the member you need
to decide what role to give that member
a role includes a set of permissions
that determines which operations the
member is allowed to perform
cloud iam provides several predefined
roles that include a combination of
these permissions
they include things like the ability to
view or edit data sets
and the ability to run queries and store
data which are built to the project
it is also possible to create custom
roles these allow you to bundle one or
more permissions
into a role to meet your specific needs
you will have to manage your custom role
as new features
permissions and services are added to
google cloud
so for this reason we recommend sticking
to pre-defined roles
you can always assign more than one
predefined role to a member
together the member and the role make up
the policy
which is then applied to a specific
resource the policy could be attached to
a specific table
data set or the gcp project itself
at the project level permissions apply
to all current
and future data sets that are part of
the project let's see how it works in a
specific scenario
suppose you're a retail company with two
groups of data analysts
the first group analyzes your retail
sales and the second analyzes customer
service requests
these two types of data are stored in
separate data sets within your project
both groups of analysts need full access
read and write to the data set that they
work on
and access to run queries in the project
let's head to the console and set up the
policies
you'll start by giving the sales analyst
the bigquery data editor role for the
retail sales data set
to set roles at the data set level
select the data set from resources
then click share data set near the right
hand side of the window
on the data set permissions tab enter
the entity you want to add into the add
members text box
for select a role select bigquery data
editor and click add
then click done then follow the same
steps to give the customer service
analyst the bigquery data editor role
for the customer service data set
you'll notice we're using google groups
to grant roles google groups are a
convenient way to create a policy for a
collection of users
you can grant and change access for a
whole group at once instead of
individual users one at a time
then you can easily add or remove
members directly from the google group
itself
giving the analyst the data editor role
at the data set level gives them the
ability to access all the tables within
that particular data set
but it does not give them the permission
to actually run queries built to that
project
for that they must be granted the
project level role called bigquery user
to grant roles at the project level you
will need to head to the navigation
window
hover over iam and admin and then click
to select iam
at the top of the screen click add in
the new members box enter both email
addresses to represent your analyst
groups
select the bigquery user role and click
save
now your two teams are ready and
equipped to analyze their data
securely if you want to learn more about
bigquery check out the rest of our
playlist and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel on youtube for other
great content
look out for our next episode of
bigquery spotlight and remember
stay curious
[Music]